[Musik]
halt deine fresse man viele von euch
haben sich mal wieder glocke für mich
deswegen hab ich bin einen blog ihr
fragt euch wahrscheinlich versucht habe
den sechsten blocks das passiert wollte
sondern im leben interessant ist
eigentlich gar nichts ja
[Musik]
wissen sie was nicht schon die ganze
zeit depot mäßig in meiner wohnung noch
machen wollte ich finde da vorne fehlt
irgendwie irgendwas schönes jetzt ist
aber schön ist wenn also ein kollege von
mir übrigens auch rat hier an der hat
sich irgendwie seit karneval eine
einfahrt und wohnt jetzt seit zwei
wochen bei mir und ich habe übrigens
gestern meine terrasse hier gestoppt und
das gibt jetzt so krass sauber hier
alles aus ja die terrasse war vorher
sehr sehr dreckig spielen vielleicht
unser plan jetzt dass wir ein paar
erledigungen erstmal machen also ich muß
ein paket zur post bringen da müssen wir
noch in rhede ich muss noch in dem haus
und zog er allerdings schon ein bisschen
länger und sie wissen dass morgen ein
besonderer tag ist und was ist meine
welt
deswegen haben wir uns überlegt dass
alle bestellungen von bildern des 20
wesentlich schweizer immobilienmarkt
alle bestellungen werden
versandkostenfrei seinem webshop kann
man als freunde wenn ihr das bestellen
wird als marke know how soll ich
wirklich keine ahnung warum wir so oft
im bauhaus unterwegs sind aber es ist
halt wirklich keine ahnung die haben
einfach alles verliere deshalb fast so
lange sie halte sie muss sich halt auch
mal so aufwickeln die natur einschätzen
soll ein paar freunde genau auf dem steg
habe ich meine instagram foto
hochgeladen
übrigens wenn ihr mal eure trasse
saubermachen wollte dann geht man dieses
ding das ist kein plate wird aber dieses
teil ist ultra gut und das sind
irgendwie sowas ist dass ihr 5 liter
oder er genau 5 liter und kostet 3 euro
allerdings braucht er auf starke muskeln
zu minimieren
unser plan ist jetzt auf jeden fall zu
ikea fahren dort ist mal was essen und
wir müssen auch noch 20.000 bilderrahmen
zu begeben
piquet hatte meine damen und herren
nächster stopp der film ein button
natürlich die ganzen bilder haben
zurückgeben
ich weiß nur das machen was aber wenn
die zwei nummern gezogen finden und eine
freundin
kommt er nochmal
für tagesgeld wird sich um drei euro
ikea ist nicht immer alles richtig mache
bin ich ein video ist eine größe warum
das schilder zu mir gesagt okay wenn
nicht wegschmeißen dann bumerangs wegen
eigentlich zurück ich habe noch nie so
viele kerzen auf einem haufen gesehen
ist ein richtiges phänomen
40.000
diese frau dahinter stecke ich das
verschlafen loch hat und macht es die
gesetze als mensch oder kann davor ja
was ihr sagen sie hat jetzt ihr auto nur
mit diesem sprösslings gewaschen jacket
ableger was ist mit ihr das ist das
wofür fegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
finde ich hab gedacht ich bringe den
parallelkanal habe jetzt gerade halt
tatsächlich im rewe 1234 in die 12 6
wasser eingekauft also finden viel spaß
beim fahren die jugend an der kamera ist
leer gegangen deswegen ich das grab mit
dem handy auf aber ich war aber der
posten habe 18 euro für ein paket
bezahlt was eine retoure ist nach
england wir sind jetzt wieder zu hause
angekommen ich hab gerade noch ein video
aufgenommen und die sonne ist auch
mittlerweile untergegangen und bin hat
grad nudeln gekocht finde ich weiß gar
nicht warum du dir da vorne gedeckt hat
wieso ist es nicht vorne beim müll wir
haben jetzt auch gegessen und ich gehe
jetzt laden zum schwimmen und finden ist
eine faule sau liegt auf der couch ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht warum ich
gerade ins schwimmen also ich bin heißer
nicht glaub ich werd krank wirst du
scheiß wetter
ich bin im djia
oh mein gott mega peinlich ich mein fach
der letzte engine und dann kamen die
bedienung von der rezeption vorne an und
hat mich einfach beim umziehen erwischt
und meint ich finde ich ja salami steaks
man auch einmal da ich wird im revier
beim bezahlen vom verkäufer gefragt ob
ich einen donut fanny messen möchte hat
mir dort angeboten
ich liebe diese strecke zurück aus mit
schirm und wie geht's dir du vorne hatte
ich habe gerade geduscht und während ich
weg war hat in der maschine hier
angestellt mit lappen drin und die
musste jetzt erstmal noch zusammen halte
ich mich dann selbst zusammenbauen
kurzfristig würde sagen das ist der
letzte koche ich hoffe dass es jetzt
werde ich habe totale macht gehe ich 33
noch bei youtube videos guckt ich sehe
zu tage fertig aus weil ich halt immer
gerade geduscht habe noch was gegessen
habe findet eh schon krank und ich
glaube ich werde gerade krank ist jetzt
auf jeden fall geben eine ausnahme
zimmer penta jetzt ich werde jetzt auch
pennen gehn freunde doch digitale das
erste mal leiter nicht richten kommen
ich nicht weiß sogar wie auch machen
geht aber ich bin mega fällig und müde
und
[Musik]